remember the day when we first met  I remember that motorcycle my best dress  he looked at me and I knew  [Music]  how simple I forced entry  [Music]  what's happened to our country we're  killing innocent people raiding other  countries preying on a weak if our  leaders if they're evil what does one do  you have a duty to the fatherland to  cherish tensa so you cannot say no prove  your race and your home you are a  traitor  [Music]  I can to a loyalty to Hitler I can't do  you think your defines it will change  the course of things  if God gives us free well we're  responsible for what we do what we fail  to do  [Music]  I can't do what I believe is wrong  [Music]  we have to stand up to evil  whatever you do I'm with you always  [Music]  you